so this is an in a standard inventory
control problem it's highly simplified
but it should give you a flavor of the
kinds of operations research problems
that business that is heavily dependent
on logistics or supply chain management
might be interested in but this is a
highly simplified version of that okay
so suppose you have a supermarket that
wants to establish an optimal inventory
plan for frozen orange juice that
balances refrigeration and delivery
costs so the idea is that if the
supermarket gets deliveries every day
based on its expected daily demand then
it won't have to store very many cases
of orange juice in the refrigerator so
it's refrigeration costs will be lower
but it'll have to take a delivery every
day and there are labor costs and
packaging costs associated with having
lots of deliveries right so you will
need to balance refrigeration costs
against the costs of deliveries and
packaging so very often you might have
to trade off those too and how might you
pick the optimal replenishment rate
every day once a week twice a month that
sort of thing ok so it's estimated that
a total of twelve hundred cases will be
sold at a steady rate during the next
year okay so obviously it is a
simplification to say that it will be a
steady rate there's probably a seasonal
profile to it and you know but you can
actually add that complexity onto this
and still preserve this the structure
this problem okay the manager plans to
play several orders of the same size
equally spaced throughout the year again
a simplification use the following Gator
determine the economic order quantity
that is the order size that minimizes
the total ordering and carrying costs so
you're trying to minimize ordering and
carrying costs the more you order the
greater your ordering cost but the less
you're carrying costs and the less you
order the more you're carrying costs and
the less you're ordering cost so or it
cost per delivery is $75 so let's say
that's the cost of the labor to deal
with the truck maybe it has built into
it some levelized cost remember we met
the term levelized in the last session
some levelized cost of packaging and it
lets say it costs eight dollars in
electricity to refrigerate one case of
orange juice for one year okay now so
one so let's say so what we're trying to
do is to find the optimal order quantity
that is we know that over the course of
the year we're going to order 1,200
cases that's the total demand over the
course of the year we want to know are
we going to order 1,200 cases one day in
one year or are we going to order make
three orders actually probably more like
five orders per business day and so on
right so let that order quantity be
called X so that's the total number of
cases that you order per order n is the
number of orders per year okay so it's
got to be the case
that x times n is equal to 1 1200 right
you want the annual order to be 1200 so
one constraint on our solution is going
to be xn is equal to 1200 then I know
that the inventory cost is the total of
delivery costs and refrigeration costs
well that's 75 dollars per order so
there are n orders so that's 75 times n
plus eight dollars per case of our
induce in average inventory okay wine
average inventory because once again
it's the levelized cost concept actually
in this case we've sort of levelized it
by design because I tell you to simplify
we're going to order the same amount
each time okay but what's going to
happen let's say suppose that I'm
watering 1200 suppose I order a hundred
units each order and I put our order in
once a month okay so at the beginning of
the month I'll end up with a hundred
units in stock demand comes through at a
constant rate so my by the middle of the
month my hundred units will go down to
50 and by the end of the month my 50
units will go down to zero okay and then
the first day of the next month I get a
hundred again so let's think about how
refrigeration costs would work and that
and this is it's worth actually drawing
that out over time
okay so let's say this is 12 months this
is time in months and you're going to
order this is the order size what do we
call it eggs right and also so order
side actually so that's not X that's
order size x is here so that's how much
you'd order at the beginning this is
inventory level you're going to run run
that down and the next day you're going
to order another and so on okay and I
should probably put one of those fancy
things they do here right to say we
don't know how far away 12 is ok well
this graph it gives you the profile of
inventory over time for any order size x
that you choose right and because I've
constrained my total orders to my total
order quantity annually to be 1200 if I
choose an ex I also determine an N ok
now so what is the refrigeration cost
associated with my choice of X ok well i
can simply take the midpoint of each of
these cycles
in other words the average of this value
and this value and x eight dollars and
i'll know what my total refrigeration
cost will be does everyone see that
because this unit the o these X units
are going to I'm going to pay you know
I'm going to pay a refrigeration cost on
them for in you know for a long time but
so let's say that every day I lose one
and let's say X was thirty 30 days in a
month then the first unit I'll lose it
in one day so I'll only pay
refrigeration costs for one day the
second unit i'll pay for two days the
third unit i'll pay for three days and
so on and it turns out if you if you're
interested in it of course it turns out
that the total cost will be the area
under this curve which is going to be
half times this base or half times this
height or if you like the average of
this number and this which is zero so
that's half of x times eight dollars
okay you
X represents the know it represents your
order quantity how much you replenish
your store with when you order so right
so let's say you order 101 but you were
okay so if you do that then you say you
wouldn't you'd end up ordering a little
bit less than 12 times a year right
because your total order has to be 1200
so let's say you order a hundred okay
and you ordered 12 times a year then big
you're going to do it once a month lets
it beginning of the month you order a
hundred your refrigerator has a hundred
units of juice and every day people come
through your store and buy juice add a
constant rate so they're they're buying
at the rate of a hundred a month right
so they're buying at the rate of a
hundred a month you bought a hundred at
the beginning of the month by the end of
the month you'll be at zero right so
yeah so your inventory level this is
your inventory level it starts out at a
hundred and the course of the month
it'll get to zero and the next day
you'll stock it back up and so on but
you want to know ok what's the
refrigeration cost hmm so it's going to
be for those hundred units there's going
to be some units that were there's you
know there's going to be some units that
stick around for 30 days some units that
stick around for 29 days some units that
stick around for 28 and so on if it
sticks around for 29 days then how much
will be the cost it's going to be eight
dollars divided by 12 because eight
dollars eight dollars is the cost to
refrigerate one case for one year so
so you'll have your average inventory is
50 exactly okay so on average this will
be your inventory and you can just
assume without having to look at this or
or you know abstracting from this you
can just assume that your refrigeration
cost is going to be in that case 50
times eight but 50s if we chose X equal
to so it's really going to be X divided
by 2 times 8 every that's for the whole
year yes so this is this is annual
inventory cost okay and what is that its
annual delivery cost plus annual
refrigeration cost well how many orders
do you have in a year n how much does
each order cost 75 so that's your annual
delivery costs and that is your annual
refrigeration cost okay so setting this
problem up is actually requires a bit of
thinking you see that's why I want you
to understand the intuition behind this
calculus because setting up the problem
it's not a set of cookbook recipes you
can't just say well here's a function
I'm going to take a derivative and set
it equal to zero minimize or maximize
life is not like that right nobody tells
you that there's here's a function that
you have to take a derivative of except
in my midterm so but you have to set up
a problem I have to know what is the
function that I've got to either find
the minimum or maximum off and that's
what we reconstructed here okay and it's
not always going to be obvious sometimes
in problem set
it might you might tear your hair out a
little bit a little bit to do this okay
but that's the way that real-world
problems work the practice you get go
through to construct those problems will
help you ok so here is the here's the
the expression for annual cost and here
is a constraint that we know we know the
total demand is equal to 1200 so we know
that n times x has to equal that okay
well you can actually you can solve for
n or X and substitute in here this is
what we learn to do in the last session
ok so here I've solved for n and
substituted for n in this equation so
instead of 75 n I have 75 x 1200 / x so
that's 90,000 over X plus 4x that's
total annual cost as a function of X X
is a number that I get to choose and i'm
going to choose it now in the most
optimal way possible okay in i'm going
to choose the X that minimizes total
cost and I built into this expression
both the cost that comes from
refrigeration and delivery okay well now
you know that ok I have to minimize this
function now you know what to do you can
apply the cookbook recipe which is what
I exist here's some muttering over there
Alan do you want to tell us okay take
the derivative of this set it equal to
zero and find the values of x for which
that's true right so we take the
derivative here just apply the power
rule this is really ninety thousand
times X to the minus two sorry times X
to the minus one so when I take the
derivative it becomes minus ninety
thousand X to the minus two plus four
set that equal to zero and solve for x
and you will get since this is X to the
squid you'll get a positive and negative
root your answer here is x equals plus
150 or minus 150 but you can reject the
minus 150 because you you know what
you've constructed excise it's the order
size and it cannot be minus yes you had
you this one oh that's oh oh this is
recall your your laws of exponents and
this is just from your primer one to the
X is the same as X to the minus one okay
or 12 the x squared is X to the minus
two okay so that's your that's your
answer okay and if if these numbers were
different let's say that 75 let's say
that your packaging costs or your
delivery cost was much higher and your
refrigeration cost was much lower hmm if
you would then what's going to happen if
your refrigeration cost is lower
you're going to want to keep more
inventory and order less so X is going
to increase your optimal order quantity
will increase you'll you'll tend to have
higher levels of inventory on average
okay and this kind of relationship so
the price of Labor or the price of
packaging relative to the price of
energy determines choices that everybody
individuals businesses governments make
about their business processes or about
their energy demand which obviously have
impacts on the economy and dents on the
environment so here you've seen a sort
of a full-blown example of a sentence
that I used yesterday or at the
orientation when I said the structure of
a capitalist economy often almost
completely determines the impact on the
environment well what is the structure
of that capitalist economy its prices
prices are central to market economy so
changes in these relative prices will
change whether we're using more
packaging and less energy or more labor
and less energy and vice versa okay yes
right that's right but you see when you
know in America most supermarkets
actually have an average life between
renovations of four years that's very
short okay so what that means is that
when you dis when when these this
relative
price is determined it effects
supermarket design for the next four
years on average so these prices will
affect how a large chain will determine
how many refrigerators they're going to
have you know they it's not that it's
not that you know basically in the very
short term in the day-to-day analysis of
course the amount the refrigerator size
is fixed but when you start to scale
back you realize that these choices
these design choices are themselves the
result of of these prices and also but
also they're also affected by interest
rates it actually it has not this is not
about the price of orange juice at all
it's about the relationship between the
price of Labor and the price of energy
that's basically the key trade-off that
we're looking at you know if you well
when you design when you design a new
build you you will you you will have in
mind that I want X percentage of my
space devoted to refrigeration and that
percentage is going to be higher or
lower depending on this trade-off yes
yes and if if this would say this was
four dollars say this was four dollars I
would go from 150 I might go to 200 far
far fewer times but larger quantities
that'll that'll encourage you to have
more refrigeration space devoted to your
new build the next time you build a new
supermarket yes yes yes and up and the
real operations research problems like
this are you know they're not toy
problems like this but nevertheless they
have embedded in them building blocks
that have trade-offs that look just like
this there may be lots of different
trade-offs but nevertheless the
trade-offs broken down will be simple
enough yeah but you would you yes but
but there are other complications for
example there you have some variables
are not worth incorporating into your
analysis because even if you
incorporated them the impact on your
optimal choice might be small for
example it's generally the case that
energy costs have have been negligible
in many American planning decisions
because of the structure of energy costs
in the US relative to everything else
but the nature of relative prices in
other countries where there are heavy
energy taxes means that their entire
landscape looks different simply because
of energy costs you know suburbs for
example don't make any sense when if you
have gasoline at
you know six or seven dollars a gallon
which is sort of us close to a price in
Italy let's say okay okay so it's almost
nine o'clock there are lots of other
examples like this in your slides I
encourage you to try at least some of
them out if you have problems come and
talk to me just second Kathy and next
time we will talk about multivariate
functions and will lop off a little from
integration yet
you